i am curious is happiness really like a
burrito like it is for this character
have you ever found happiness and food
in at any time
i find only happiness and food
really weirdly i flew back from
had to go do some pre-production stuff
on the next movie i'm doing so i've been
in london for five days i got back to la
last night and i landed at 6 30 at night
and i text my wife
straight away when i got in the car
saying i need mexican food
like i just had it you know when you get
something in your head that's the only
thing that will satisfy you
so um i actually didn't have any burrito
last night but i had like
tacos last night um so and i was
definitely in a happy place when i when
i got home because the postmates like it
arrived as my car got back from the
airport and arrived literally at the
same time so i didn't even have to wait
for the food it was it was amazing
for me it usually involves dark
chocolate but i completely understand so
well i'm curious i mean when this
came your way how much were you actually
told did you get to read all of the
scripts did you have to wait to read
some of them because i i think these
writers are great i've seen a lot of
their stuff but
their stories are always kind of insane
yeah they're always mad and they're
always very hard to predict
um
and i too have been keeping a bit of an
eye on jack and harry and what they've
been doing and they've been having a
good run you know whether it's stuff
that they've written or stuff that
they've been creatively involved in are
producing um
that
i feel like they're on a purple patch
and uh i i think when it first came my
way
there was only maybe episodes one to
three
um
maybe then i spoke to them
after one to three then they let me read
four
and then we went to work like it was
crazy because then
four and five five and six weren't
written
fully written until we were out in
australia shooting so
and they changed you know and they
changed a lot in some ways
but um
and we did you know we did a couple of
alternate endings and we all played
around with stuff but uh
that was enough to know
to that it was something i wanted to be
involved in there was some
i feel like there was just so much going
on
and so many
exciting and unexpected
twists along the way
and things for me to to grab a hold of
as an actor that i was i was in what was
it like to finally read that last script
once it was finished and learned where
you would leave things
well i was i've never
i don't think i've ever worked harder in
my life than i have on on this job and
it was like
the longest shoot i've ever done
and the hardest shoot for physically
mentally so many reasons my character's
never in some calm state you know so it
was an easy day at work you know it's
always this mad
state of flux that he was in
um
but i uh
as a result of just constantly working
and i had so few days off
um
when six came in
finished
it took me a while to get to it to be
able to find the time
i'm also coming home to you know three
kids and you know the madness of home
life and they were all out there with me
and so it was you know
my weekends were insane as well as as my
weekdays when i was working you know so
i took i i read six probably later than
certainly later than danielle mcdonald
because she
she texts me going like oh my god have
you read six
and i was like no
she was like please read it please read
it and get back to me and i was like
okay
um and then it probably took me another
week before i even got to reading it to
be honest but um
yeah just um
like every other episode unexpected
um
uh
but but i loved it and i and i kind of
you know we were only ever
we were only ever making one of these it
was only ever
like let's just do one series
and you know that remains
the the setup but i know there's
i know there's certainly when you can
ireland and australia and anywhere
that's seen it and the reception's been
so insane there's definitely a demand
and a want for more
so
we'll talk about that
let's see what happened
ultimately turn out to be anything that
you thought he would be from reading
those first three scripts
you know i think you always have a bit
of an idea
of what you're going to do with the
character or how the character is going
to be portrayed or or um
how he's going to land with people and
then ultimately
there's so many mitigating factors that
alter that
you know um and i think
probably
for the man more than any other
character like he
ended up becoming something
just other maybe than i expected him to
be and i felt um
this sounds so silly based on the
premise of the show but i felt like i
was constantly finding new stuff about
him because i was you know and that was
my process for this character which is
different to any process i've ever done
for any character i've played it's like
trying to
trying to block out anything that was
revealed about him so that it felt fresh
and as a result i felt like he kept
changing
and
in
in my mind and in my portrayal of him
kept altering as the information was
given to me you know which is unlike
anything else i've done before you know
so um
yeah i think the audience
go on this crazy ride
of discovery with him
some of it really
funny and interesting
much of it dark you know um
so that was never a dull moment
you had belfast and barbara and star go
to vista del mar both come out the same
year last year people loved both of
those movies even though they couldn't
be more different from each other
so how do you feel about the responses
you've heard from fans when it comes to
those projects are you surprised that
people reacted to them the way that they
did yeah i mean i probably
haven't done a deep deep dive into the
proper sort of fan reaction to them but
like i know on a general level that
there's a lot of love i you know
critically we got a lot of love
obviously for both those films
um
and that's a cool thing when they're so
different and you've offered up a very
different side of yourself
uh to both be received in that way it's
satisfying it's cool you know it's it's
it's what you want you want to
constantly be mixing it up and changing
people's perception and idea of you as
an actor i think
um
so it's been it's been a good thing and
then you know so far i don't know what's
like in the states yet but in the uk and
ireland and australia and everything the
reception to the tourists has been so
off the charts great that it's like
it's i it's it's the first time in my
career i've been sitting here with three
movies or three projects in a row that
have been received this well so i'm just
trying to enjoy that
uh i know it's not always the way of it
um
but i will i will lap it up and i'll
enjoy it whilst it whilst it remains you
know it's uh
it's been cool and again
the tourist is something totally
different again all together and
and and i love that and i want to keep
doing that you know i want that to be
my career i want to constantly be
playing with people's idea of
of
who they think i am you know that's
exciting to me
how does that affect the next choice i
mean how what what goes into the
thinking of like what you're working on
now how did you come to deciding that
that would be the next project is this
the challenge
it's simply that it's always like what's
a challenge what what what you know you
can never predict where your head is
going to be in a year two years three
years so you can never be like
i've always said this you cannot plan in
this industry you can't no matter who
you are what's offered to you or you
know whether you have can't get an
audition for two years or whether you're
being offered every single job in the
world for your career you can't really
plan in a big way because you can you
you can change you can go well i've just
had this experience on this job and it's
made me feel like the next thing i want
to do is this so the next thing i want
to do that
and you don't know how that's going to
be until the experience has happened
and
you know
i feel very lucky always have for the
last
10 years let's say that i've had a
choice in what i do
and i want to make the most of that
choice and
i have uh the next thing i'm doing this
heart of stone for netflix is is like a
very different world than i've been in
before
uh just as barbara's star was a very
different world and belfast burst is a
million different worlds than i've been
in before so
that's exciting to me you know and i
want to keep mixing it up and working
with
cool people that that that will
challenge me um
so
yeah i feel that that's how i've ended
up doing what i'm what i'm doing next
and
you know i
i i have a pretty good idea of what i'm
doing
as much as i said i don't want to plan
you you can't plan i'm trying to only
because i've
written something as well that that is
in in my
future
of uh making that so
again that's a million miles away from
everything i've done so like
just constantly trying to mix it up and
challenge yourself i guess is is what
leads you to these these choices
well thank you for talking to me about
it and thank you for keeping me on my
toes because now i'm at the point where
i have no idea what you're going to be
in next or who the character is going to
be and i love that as a viewer so thank
you
thank you
thank you